what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
right off the bat spoiler warning if you
have not seen spider-man no way home we
are about to dive into some spoilers for
that film so you should click away now
if you are still with me i had to kind
of lie about the title and put rumor in
the title so i didn't spoil it for those
who haven't seen no way home but tom
holland has finally addressed he has
finally talked about the other two
in spider-man no way home and what it
was like to work with them after going
all of this time and everybody denying
that they are all three in spider-man
knowing home andrew garfield saying that
he's not the werewolf toby pretty much
staying quiet about everything and tom
doing his absolute best to not spoil
everything and he didn't all for us to
get that epic moment on screen that we
saw where we saw andrew garfield and
then toby maguire show up after finally
experiencing that in an interview on
marvel's website directly we have
zendaya and tom holland talking about
what it was like to have andrew garfield
and toby mcguire on the set so let's
check out what tom and zendaya had to
say about working with the other two
spider-man and of course if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on all of the
latest mcu news so like i said this is
coming directly from marvel's website
and the article is titled spider-man no
way home tom holland and zendaya on new
and returning surprise characters now if
i wasn't so sick still and it wasn't so
hard to talk i would go over all of
these but i'm just gonna go over a few
and let's start with charlie cox because
that was an awesome surprise even though
some of us knew it was coming it was
still insanely exciting to see on screen
it starts off by saying does that suit
cane and glasses combination look
familiar yes charlie cox is once again
playing matt murdock making a surprise
appearance to offer peter mae parker and
happy legal advice and he's a very good
lawyer tom holland said we had so much
fun working with charlie it's really
interesting doing a scene between two
superheroes that has no real superhero
stuff in it apart from the bit when he
catches the brick it was awesome zendaya
then says i didn't get to be there in
which tom holland said you weren't there
for that oh you were there for that in
which zendaya said i was there for the
behind the scenes watching you guys but
i didn't get to be in it and tom holland
said but it was great i loved working
with charlie now like i said i'm not
going to go over all of these but i do
want to talk about what tom had to say
about willem dafoe because i think he
just absolutely crushed his character
returning after years and years and
years of playing the green goblin he
came back and absolutely killed the role
it says if that cackle sends a chill
down your spine you're not alone
returning as norman osborne slash the
green goblin defoe is downright
terrifying though peter does think he
kind of looks like a green elf at first
tom holland says i've never worked with
an actor who was able to give a director
so many options he has this one speech
in the film where he's talking about
peter's kind of existential crisis and
he and then zendaya cut him off and said
scared the hell out of everyone to be
honest tom then said he must have done
that scene 30 times and they were all
different in which zendaya said the
coolest thing is that everyone's so
lovely and then they just play these
very evil characters he's so good at
just like being lovely you know hey how
are you and then green goblin like whoa
and now here's what tom holland ins and
dey had to say about working with tobey
maguire and andrew garfield it says last
seen on screen as spider-man in 2007
mcguire's version of the character
enters this multiverse to help out
holland's peter now older and wiser he
serves as a spidey mentor of sorts to
the young hero tom holland toby was so
funny zendaya he was so cool tom holland
says we have so many little inside jokes
that came up from working with toby
definitely not your dad he says and
that's a quote and i'm assuming an
inside joke zendaya then says t mcgee in
which tom holland also says t mcgee man
he was so funny he was really excited to
be back you could tell it really meant a
lot to him him putting the suit on again
us getting back together it was awesome
zendaya says that first day i was so
nervous for you in which tom says yeah i
was stressed zendaya said we had to do a
rehearsal and me and jacob felt like
your parents tom jokes and says dropping
me off at school zendaya says like
dropping you off at kindergarten for the
first day like i hope the other kids
like him and like i hope he doesn't come
back crying and so we were just there
and i was taking pictures of you guys so
that you could have it it was so cute
tom then says you do have some amazing
pictures of us zendaya i do i do but
yeah he was so lovely and hilarious
unintentionally sometimes and tom's
final words were he's hilarious and i'm
hoping at least one point in time on set
behind the scenes there is a video or
picture somewhere out there of all three
spider-man or at least toby and tom
doing the emo parker dance
now i just love what they said about
toby about how excited he was to be back
and that it really meant a lot to him to
be back because he's my spider-man he's
the spider-man that i grew up with he's
the one that i'll always have the
biggest emotional attachment to and the
fact that he was excited to return and
it meant a lot to him means a lot to me
and i'm sure many other people out there
as well and i personally really loved
that he played the older type of mentor
type to peter parker to not just our
peter parker but to andrew as well he
has that scene with andrew where he
tells him you know don't give up on love
it was hard for me and mj but we made it
work and i do love the role that andrew
garfield got to play and what it meant
to him and here's what tom and zendaya
had to say about working with andrew it
says last seen on screen as spider-man
in 2014 garfield returns to the
character to once again crawl up the
walls alongside maguire's version of the
character garfield works to help
holland's peter with the challenges he's
currently facing tom holland says andrew
garfield the legend himself he's such a
lovely guy i think this film was his way
of making peace with spider-man it was
such a privilege to work with him i know
that it meant a lot to him then zendaya
says some really touching words here she
says it was so beautiful to see toby
andrew and tom care so deeply about the
characters and what their characters
what their journey had been as
spider-man it was so beautiful to see
all of you guys connect on that and be
able to talk to each other about such a
special experience that very few people
have been able to don the suit it was so
great to see how much you guys all
really cared and had each other's back
it was really sweet in which tom holland
replied it's like a brotherhood now i
personally really love this and i
actually have to agree with what tom
holland said here it does feel like this
was sort of a redemption moment for
andrew garfield you know the amazing
spider-man movies get a lot of hate and
that's not andrew's fault i actually
think he's a fantastic spider-man but
this film spider-man no way home he
really shined especially for me i think
that he did an incredible job and he was
my favorite part of the movie one of
them at least every time we talked about
gwen and when he talked about not
holding back his punches anymore got me
choked up and when he caught mj that was
such a perfect scene in such a
redemption moment for him i cried all of
the times when i watched this movie
during this part and then you have the
scene where he's talking to toby and
toby's like wait a second you're amazing
you're amazing and he says not gonna lie
i needed to hear that you can tell that
this is really about andrew and his
films it's two part right because he's
the amazing spider-man toby is saying
you're amazing but also you have to
imagine that andrew felt kind of bad
about how fans reacted to the films and
this is toby saying no you're amazing
you're an amazing spider-man and i think
that was overall just an insanely cool
scene and i look forward to getting to
know more about what happened behind the
scenes i look forward to the behind the
scenes videos where we see all of them
interacting together no doubt they'll
release those over time i mean this was
kind of secretly released on marvel's
website it wasn't advertised that much
because obviously marvel and sony are
still trying to keep the other
spider-man a secret but of course it'll
all come out probably pretty soon but in
the meantime let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
and what was your favorite part of
spiderman no way home don't forget to
like the video and subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos and of
course for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you